thank you for being on the program
coronavirus of course affecting every
part of the United Kingdom is Scotland
prepared yes we are prepared done we're
preparing all the time our preparations
have different strands to them we're
working with other nations in the UK to
understand the science to listen to what
it is telling us about what we
potentially face and the weeks and
months to come and also listening to
what the science tells us about the
potential actions we can take to try to
slow down the spread of the virus reduce
the peak of people who are infected at
any one time but right now of course we
remain in the containment phase that
means identifying confirmed cases making
sure that everybody they've been in
contact with is traced and followed up
and given the appropriate advice trying
very much to reduce and stop prevent the
spread from individual to individual
another strand of course extremely
important is making sure our National
Health Service is ready to scale up the
response that it is able to provide and
all other NHS boards have very clear
escalation plans in place about what
they would do if demand from
coronaviruses to rise in the weeks ahead
so there is a wealth of preparation
underway looking at how we better
support vulnerable people people who
might be asked to self isolate to means
that they will be in a position of not
being paid for it for the work that
they're doing so it's a serious
situation we face and that's true of all
of the government's across the UK but
we're taking it seriously and were doing
everything possible to mitigate it as
far as we possibly can you were talking
about the potential need for the NHS to
scale up and we just heard from the
Chancellor ashisu knack who was saying
that the budget could potentially
contain measures to help the NHS more
funding perhaps for the NHS if necessary
this of course will have a knock-on
effect in Scotland do you think that
more funding will be needed for the
Health Service in Scotland and also
across trusts the UK yes I think that is
pretty much inevitable that we will need
additional resources for our National
Health Service although of course we are
at right now working within the
resources that are available to the
Health Service Scotland has just passed
its budget for the year ahead which in
itself delivers record funding
for the National Health Service but the
pressures that are likely to come from
coronavirus in the weeks ahead it will
mean that we need to see additional
resources so I very much hope that the
budget has positive things to see about
that we also want to continue to talk to
the UK government about how we do
support people in there what we describe
is the gig economy I certainly hope that
we'll see a relaxation of universal
credit rules we don't want people who
are being advised to self isolate to
minimize the risk of passing the
infection on to others to be sanctioned
on their benefit so there's so much to
do all of the governments across the UK
are what can very closely and very
constructively together as people have a
right to expect I'll participate
tomorrow and the kobra meeting that the
Prime Minister will chair just as I did
last week the Scottish Government's own
resilience committee which is only
equivalent of Cobra has been operational
for some time so there are serious plans
being implemented and you know again
we've got to stress well two things to
the public one this is a serious
situation but the vast majority of
people who get this virus will have very
mild symptoms and recover reasonably
quickly it will be a smaller number of
people who perhaps become more seriously
ill and the focus therefore is making
sure that our NHS is equipped to provide
them with the care and the treatment
that they need but the second point is
the one that all politicians have been
making now consistently for some days
the public have a part to play in
helping us to contain and then slow down
the spread of the virus by following all
the personal hygiene advice that is the
year about hand washing what to do when
you cough and sneeze all of that really
matters and it really makes a difference
now you of course have been fully
briefed on the outbreak you've been in
the cobra meetings last week you'll be
in the one tomorrow the Sunday Times
claims this morning that ministers are
preparing for a coronavirus death toll
in the region of hundred thousand people
is that correct well we're looking at
the scientific watch case scenarios
right now and we've heard other figures
in the past the number of days that up
to 80% of the population could be
infected with the vast majority at my
Audley so these kind of figures are very
much watch case scenarios what our focus
No is on working out with the benefit of
the best scientific advice what measures
we can and need to take to reduce that
impact as much as possible when we write
to say probably is a key software now
look I'm not I'm not going to we're
looking at worst-case scenarios and
these kind of figures are broadly in
terms of the worst case scenario figures
that we face but these are not forecasts
and I think this is the important point
worst-case scenarios reasonable
worst-case scenarios are not forecasts
of what will necessarily happen and I
think for about a point of public
assurance it's it's important to be
clear about that but we are looking at a
range of measures that we can take I was
going to see when we move into the de
lis fees from the contingent fees and
it's probably no a case of when not if
and that will be done in a phased way
that are a number of options that
ministers collectively can take in order
to slow down the spread of the virus
over the next number of weeks that will
be the priority slowing down the spread
so that the number of people infected at
any one time is reduced and that makes
it more possible for a National Health
Service and wider society to cope so
there are some difficult judgments that
governments are going to have to take
but it is important that we do
everything we possibly can to mitigate
the impact talking about those difficult
judgments and Glasgow is hosting the
climate change summit in November our
preparations for that at risk because of
coronavirus right now preparations are
continuing preparations are intensifying
and the work around that between the UK
government and the Scottish Government
Glasgow City Council the police and a
range of other partners are progressing
very well and it's important that that
work continues right now
that is no suggestion that that will not
take place in November of this year but
we are in an evolving situation and all
ministers acting responsibly have to be
very clear that everything has to remain
under review because we need to make
sure that we are taking the
responsibility to limit the impact on
the population as much as possible very
seriously so of course events that are
coming up in the the months to come it
will be under review but there will be a
balance we're all seeking to strike
doing everything we can and everything
we need to do even if it involves
difficult decisions
to protect the public as much as
possible on the one hand but of course
striving as hard as we can to have
business as usual as much as possible as
well so tough tough judgements and in a
situation like this it is really
important that all of us as politicians
it resists the temptation to do things
for political expediency sometimes it's
easy to do things that make it look as
if politicians are acting but what we
must do is listen to the science try to
understand what that tells us and take
the actions that are going to have the
biggest impact on protecting the public
as much as possible it's a big
responsibility on all of us and we all
have to seek to rise to that challenge
talking about rising to that challenge
and you of course have been involved in
those meetings with the Prime Minister
what do you make of the government's
response to coronavirus well all of the
governments are working together across
the UK and I think we are all working as
hard as we can and as best we can to
make sure we've got the right response
there are a multitude of things that I
will no doubt talk to you about in in
months to come that will be critical of
Boris Johnson I'm sure he will of things
that he is critical of me over that's
the the nature of politics but I don't
intend to get into a position of
criticizing the UK government over this
because I want us to work together if we
have differences of opinion about how to
deal with it and that's not the case at
the moment I should say then we work
through these but it's really important
and I think the public have a right to
expect that all of us in a position of
responsibility and in a leadership
position what together and do the right
things to protect the public